hey guys what's going on a reminder next
week Tuesday at 12:00 a.m. meaning
Monday night my special is dropping on
Netflix no pain so get that in your
queue set a reminder or whatever the
hell you want to say on Netflix but it's
coming to you Late Late Late Monday
night and if your true baby you're gonna
listen to that Monday night you're gonna
watch it Monday night and if you're even
if you know you can still also maybe you
got to go to sleep even though we're all
not really doing anything cuz roll on
lockdown but the special no pain my
fourth special my third Netflix special
comes out on Netflix
April 14th so I'll be ready for that and
that being said welcome to episode 167
of congratulations
[Music]
it's episode 167 we did it and we
finally got to 167 and it's [ __ ]
we're doing it do it and this is the
fourth week maybe that I've gone to in
quarantine gone out for limited amounts
of things got out for limited amounts of
things limited-edition this is tops
baseballs limited edition adding adding
syllables this is when they used to sell
the baseball cards you're looking at the
embossed upper deck drew bledsoe die-cut
limited edition so annoying already yeah
yes dude why do you listen to it
[ __ ] NPR said that they didn't want
to have me on to promote my special you
know what dude it's probably because all
the [ __ ] that I was saying about [ __ ]
NPR on this [ __ ] if you want the real
news though you come to congratulations
the only trusted news source dude [ __ ]
this NPR [ __ ] I know it's like dude you
want to talk about [ __ ] what's going
on in the world or you want to talk
about what's secretly really going on in
the world dude
I'm drinking dude I'm drinking my
[ __ ] it's the nighttime podcast dude
I've never done a podcast at night I've
done 0 podcasts at night and now I've
done a podcast and I can't say that
anymore
so that's it this is a [ __ ] no way
that means that I've done this on at
night time that if that this podcast is
the nighttime podcast is that it's a
limited edition nighttime podcast for
only four dollars only for though you
might think that we for 50 grand
four dollars okay so yeah so that's
what's up
and the next the Netflix special is
coming out can't wait for that
[ __ ] to show all the stars in
line I'm happy with it my brother
directed the [ __ ] out of it and that's
that I had a [ __ ] cool thing that TMZ
reported it must have been a slow news
day for celebrities dude that they
[ __ ] dug into the Chris D'Elia files
of last week but I I did I went to get
something out at at a convenience store
I'm not gonna tell you if it was CVS or
Walgreens or well now he knows either
one of those because I can't think of
another one anyway and I can't remember
what I was going to get but I was gonna
get something and then I there was
somebody checking out I put the store on
my Instagram but there was somebody
checking out in front of me and there
was a guy behind the counter checking
her out like I don't mean like checking
her out like god damn baby I mean like
checking around like at the cash
register and so the guy from police
academy anyway so I he was checking her
out and I said to him through my [ __ ]
n95 mask cuz I got one and you can say
that I should [ __ ] drop drop it off
at cedars-sinai but dude like come on
you know I was ahead of the game on this
mask [ __ ] people like you shouldn't be
having one you shouldn't have one you
should give it you should donate it oh
yeah and now what are they saying what's
the [ __ ] who's saying oh you should
have masks okay so your boy was a little
bit on the [ __ ] cutting edge of masks
of masks masks
and so anyway through my n95 mask I say
hey man you guys have told the paper or
you all out because every time I go
everywhere that might have toilet paper
think alike they're all out sorry we're
all that start sorry I'm sorry we're all
out sorry we're all out you go anywhere
- [ __ ] it you guys have totally versa
sorry we're all out you were to
McDonald's you'd be like it's a toilet
paper the bathroom is [ __ ] has no
together we're like we're all out it
doesn't matter we just put it in the
food and so it's probably healthier to
eat dog [ __ ] than it is to make that eat
McDonald's so um anyway so I [ __ ]
said do you have toilet paper and he
looks at me says ah and he sees me
through my n95 mask and he goes like
this um yeah yeah hold on and I say oh
yeah you got the hook-up joking and he
goes like this and kind of like winks at
me and goes like yeah so I was like okay
finishes checking out the young lady and
then he goes like this follow me so I
followed the dude to the back of either
Walgreens or CVS and it was Walgreens
and so when I got to the back he goes
like this way right here and then he
went through two [ __ ] doors that by
the way there I've never walked through
doors like these you know the [ __ ]
big metal doors with the oh no not the
oval the rectangular with the rounded
edges that like cooks you I've never
walked through doors like that in my
life I've never worked the doors like
that they have at the back of Walgreens
haven't been [ __ ] like anytime
there's a cook thing like a chef is
doing it and that's it pretty much
I don't know any other place that they'd
have those doors why are those doors
only used for [ __ ] back storing and
also cooking
yeah dude [ __ ] doorknobs they don't use
that [ __ ] I guess because their hands
are full and they got anyway I'll figure
that out on my own time sorry for
digressing so he says wait right here
I wait he disappears and he comes back
with [ __ ] 24 rolls of toilet paper
and I go my jaw drop and I go damn I was
like these [ __ ] are all out but
they're secretly not all out like all
these places were all out but yeah right
the employees are [ __ ] digging into
the good stash and take it home and [ __ ]
in their [ __ ] brains out and wiping
it up dude
and walking out with a [ __ ] anus as
clean as a whistle and I meantime I got
a shitty but at Walgreens trying to
[ __ ] scrip trying to be like yeah no
let me get actually get that long
receipt because now I'm gonna use it so
the guy hands it to me and he goes like
this I'm a big fan and I go like this oh
[ __ ] my comedy has amounted to something
finally alright so and he says now this
is this tomorrow I stopped at the
Instagram cuz I don't make it too long
but this is the podcast and I'm always
hurting for content I'll keep going so
he says um yeah I'm a big fan and we had
you know this is this is the supply here
you go and he rings me up and as he
brings me up and he said you know I
gotta say I'm actually not I I started
stand-up because of you and I was like
what and he was like ya know you were
the reason I got into stand-up and I'm
like goddamn am I gonna have to break
out these excuse me sir but I'm not
gonna have to break out these toilet
papers right now to to wipe tears going
for my item I check are for my eye to my
chin am I gonna have to and he was like
yeah I you know you got you got me
through some times man you made me laugh
so there you go and gave me [ __ ] 24
rolls of toilet paper bro and you know
I'm [ __ ] to quote the wise [ __ ]
deep deep deep deep thinker LL Cool J
I'm ten times platinum and you know I'm
[ __ ] so that's that and anyway I
posted that on my Instagram story or
something no no I my Instagram regular
thing not my story and then he responded
and DM me and he was like yo dude I
appreciate you not saying my name
but I wouldn't got in trouble I'm the
manager anytime you need something
[ __ ] come on by and I'll hook you up
and I go like this I got my pandemic
buddy I got my pandemic buddy dude if I
need something he'll hook me up hey yo
so guess what dude if you need something
you come to me now I'm the [ __ ] guy
on the corner and breaking bad that is
like you know
and I'm not Aaron Paul or like Bryan
Cranston I'm the guy that he hires that
most likely get shot that's like on the
corner of the [ __ ] thing that's just
like yo you know I got what you need and
they're like how'd you get it and I'm
like Shh
but it's that blue [ __ ] yup does I have
that blue tint it has a blue tint anyway
dude I should be a [ __ ] meth dealer
for real just got into Breaking Bad for
the first time ever I won't spoil it if
anybody hasn't seen it but you should
have [ __ ] seen it it's been out ten
years and mostly I'm just saying that
because I haven't get rid of has never
seen it and I don't want to spoil it for
him but I'm I just finished season three
and wow dude this show
[ __ ] rips dude and I know it I know
you know it rips cuz everybody's seen it
unless you're like [ __ ] 12 because it
was six when you were on because you
were six when it was on and dude it
[ __ ] rips man and I felt bad cuz I'm
friends with Aaron Paul I never told him
I never saw the show and I sent him a
video saying how good it was and how
good he was and how good he was in it
and then he sent me a video back saying
thank you and he also said it couldn't
have come at a better time which means I
was probably making him happy when he
wasn't happy Hollywood
yes dude I'm [ __ ] Hollywood I'm sorry
would I move to [ __ ] France do you
understand me
I moved next to Johnny Depp in [ __ ]
France
your boys Hollywood man people who think
Hollywood is bad people think Hollywood
is evil bro whatever you think that is
that's what I am it's so annoying when
people say that people think something
extra is going on in Hollywood it's so
annoying how dumb people are when people
think something extra is going on in
Hollywood like how it's like [ __ ] oh
well you know that there's a [ __ ]
ring of pedophilia that people oh really
dude oh there's a ring of pedophilia
that the top producers know about and
confide in each other in and keep kids
and pass them around and [ __ ] them oh
really dude oh yeah or are you just
bored and sitting down a lot
[Music]
dude there's no [ __ ] pizza gate man
people think Hollywood well you know
they got in Hollywood so they could [ __ ]
kids you know that right
people who look in your eyes and say
that and you'll be like oh really
or do they just [ __ ] produce bad boys
dude do you know how bored you have let
me tell you something man and I'm not
even Will Smith level I'm not Steven
Spielberg's level you know I mean but
dude if there was some extra [ __ ] going
on I'd have heard of it I'm telling you
right now because this is your trusted
nudes new nudes source if you want [ __ ]
shots you come - congratulations calor
but if you want trusted news [ __ ] NPR
you come to you boy and I will set you
straight dude there's nothing going on
in Hollywood except for and action
that's all that's happened sure every
now and then there's a Harvey Weinstein
you understand every now and then
there's a Harvard Weinstein okay every
now and then but that's just like in
real life in real life sometimes there's
bad guys but any time it's Kevin Spacey
[ __ ] pops up people are like oh you
know you was gonna die and you know that
and you know this and that happened and
you know that's what happened and this
guy was in on it and that's why they
made this movie so they could know now
was Kevin Spacey probably did he picked
apart in 21 because he was around
[ __ ] 9 20 year olds and he could
maybe plug one in them yeah but does
that mean there's a pedophilia ring
going on does that mean that [ __ ]
pizza gate exists in DC no dude you're
just bored and you're sitting down too
much stand up go for a run you'll
realize there's no pizza gate I mean
insane this this [ __ ] notion of we
don't really know what's going on first
of all let me say this yeah you do and
second of all you shouldn't the stuff
you don't know is this stuff you
shouldn't know now pull your
[ __ ] dirty wife-beater down it's too
high over your bellybutton because dude
if you believe in that [ __ ]
you are [ __ ] out to lunch what are
you doing what is that what were you
bringing a sandwich Oh cuz I'm going out
to lunch dude you're an insane person
everything that's going on is pretty
much everything that's going on and I
don't want to know with oh you're gonna
new let the government know like Google
is starting to track people now because
of the kovat 19 and some people are like
well they shouldn't track us that's the
government they shouldn't know what the
[ __ ] we're doing at all times dude
okay government I'll write a list for
you about where the [ __ ] I go I don't
give a [ __ ] where'd he go
where am I my house the Comedy Store
even not in non covin nineteen related
times my [ __ ] where even if I go to the
strip club who gives a [ __ ] you think
dude say you're cheating on your wife
and Google is tracking your whereabouts
do you think they're gonna alert your
wife man do you think the government
gives a [ __ ] what you do with your dirty
nub just relax and stop sitting go for a
[ __ ] job dude
go swimming for [ __ ] sake wash your
hair bro pizza date the [ __ ] name of
all denied like pizza oh you know cuz
Joe Biden and [ __ ] Hillary Clinton
and they were all oh yeah oh yeah dude
oh yeah Hillary Clinton had a [ __ ]
basement in a pizza shop and was [ __ ]
nine year olds oh yeah the only [ __ ]
female that actually [ __ ] nine year
olds is the one that ran for [ __ ]
president last time or do you need to go
swimming which one is it dude what's
more likely Hillary Clinton's [ __ ] a
nine year old or you need to get dry or
you're too dry [ __ ] it up it's all
good dude it doesn't it doesn't matter
man you know it doesn't matter it's all
good
but that's the point is that there's not
some active people who think that
there's some extra [ __ ] going on dude
you just you should have lived out your
dream you should have tried a little
harder or something I get it it's boring
you're sitting behind a [ __ ] desk at
a Bank of America and you [ __ ]
googled too much you know when really
what you wanted to be was a [ __ ] rock
climber but instead you came in a woman
when you were 19 and you got a [ __ ]
eight-year-old now and you can't climb
rocks so instead you're googling
something behind a desk but don't blame
your [ __ ] non-dream on Hillary
Clinton [ __ ] a nine year old at the
bottom of a pizza place in DC the
understand do you understand life's just
boring we want excitement but it's just
boring and that's honestly awesome and
if the government is doing something
like tracking us or listening into my
[ __ ] five people are like can't trust
five g-men that'll give you give it to
me man hey hey 5g come on come on come
on 5g let's go I can't [ __ ] believe
it man
I can't believe that people will sit
there and [ __ ] well you know you know
you know anytime you talk to a guidance
well you know why anytime you're talking
to a guy and he's like well you know why
that you know why yeah I already know I
don't say it I get it get school I got
buddies that think this [ __ ] I got
buddies that I hang with that I like
that I have similarities with and
[ __ ] things that we would have called
it completely what do you call it
[ __ ] things that you have in common I
have things in common would think I
couldn't remember the word comment do it
great cool five g's getting to me and
and they'll say [ __ ] like or you know
that the [ __ ] virus the coat you know
this right the Cova
viruses man-made that they did it the
American the military in USA did it and
they and they released it in a new how
you know that right and they're acting
like I'm the [ __ ]
and to that guy I just go like this uh
yeah because you know why that guy
twelve years ago his brain went like
this it started leaking blood and
there's nothing I can do about that
excuse me but is this Minority Report
can I go back in time her time cop
whatever the [ __ ] that movie was a my
jean-claude van damme in time cop I
can't fix his brain I can't be like when
the guy says well you know whether do
you know you know why right you know why
you know what the virus really is I
can't go like this
hold on one second I will meet you
twelve years ago and then go back and
then be like hey buddy come here right
when his brains about to break and just
[ __ ] tell him what he needs to hear
so it doesn't [ __ ] go and then come
back and then be like no what were you
saying and they say nothing I it was
from it was from a bat and I go like
this yes son of a [ __ ] it was dude
speaking of Jean Claude Van Damme
have you seen jean-claude Van Damme's
YouTube channel okay look there's this
whole thing YouTube stars they came up
everyone thinks that they are [ __ ]
not act with older people people a
little older than me think that a
YouTube guy isn't a job do you not I'm
saying it is alright whether you like it
or not it's like when you know rock and
roll came out people were like oh that's
not music well guess what it is now
because it's not to be [ __ ] with
obviously YouTube is a real thing you
get guys like Kevin James that's like
I'm gonna start a YouTube channel and
make short films and he makes funny
short films and that's great because
Kevin James I think it's great I love
Kevin James I think he's [ __ ] funny
and I love junk levente you hey dude you
talking to me about jean-claude Van
Damme
you know I love jean-claude Van Damme if
I met jean-claude Van Damme I would piss
my you know it's like forget it
so but his YouTube he has a YouTube
channel and dude you just got to go see
it him and his family are just making
[ __ ] stuff and cutting it together
and there's one video where John Claude
Van Damme is walking I'm not gonna play
it because I probably can't but who is
walking and all he does is walking down
the street like this and they go
jean-claude Van Damme can I have a
handshake and he goes and kicks the hand
away and then he'll like do stuff for
like he'll turn around and be like and
there is nothing more [ __ ] French
than that when I found out was he was he
from Belgium Brussels the muscles from
Brussels dude
anyway jean-claude Van Damme's this [ __ ]
and he also is wearing for some reason a
towel around his neck so it makes him
look called Jack and he's just like hold
on before we start shooting I grab the
towel grab that ton of son-of-a-bitch
doll um anyway dude you know it is what
it is and we're talking [ __ ]
straight-up serious [ __ ] and straight-up
NPR [ __ ] news my specials coming out
and yeah there was another [ __ ] one
that was like now we don't want him on
our [ __ ] thing to promote it I looked
up what it was and they get like 7000
views and I'm like did I [ __ ] your girl
dude what I don't mean to sound like a
piece of [ __ ] but yeah this would be
good for you man nuts oh dude I can't
believe
think that there's a [ __ ] for real
pizza gate I know that's old news but so
yeah so all right let me do these
[ __ ] ads my babies love when you
listen to these ads dude love when you
listen to these ads now the cool thing
about it is no matter what I can't find
where I put it and here it is ray Colin
hmm you guys look around you I don't
have to tell you it's a wireless world
but it is and you know it
everyone needs a great pair of wireless
earbuds but before you go dropping
hundreds of dollars on a pair you need
to check out the wireless earbuds from
Ray Khan you already know ray con
earbuds start at about half the price of
any other premium wireless earbuds in
the market and that they sound just as
amazing as any other top audio brands
you know their newest model that
everyday e25 eetu v earbuds are the best
ones yet with six hours of playtime
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass and
a more compact design that gives you a
nice noise isolating fit dude I have
them and they're awesome and let me tell
you something two other ones and I'm not
gonna name them they remain nameless for
now but they fall out of your ear I jog
around I move around
I do box jumps your boys fit alright
sometimes I just bend over to get some
of the needs go King ticking ding ding
down a drain well these redcon ones they
stick in your ear because they're made
for humans anyway they're stylish and
discreet no dangling wires no stems wink
you're not I'm talking about now's the
time to get the latest and greatest from
Ray Khan get 15% off your order at buy
rake on Comm / Congrats that's buy rake
on Comm / congrats for 15% off mic on
wireless earbuds buy rake on Comm /
Congrats I'm telling you man these are
the ones quip quip makes electric
toothbrushes and they are the makers of
the quip electric toothbrush and they
want you to know that one single
discovery is the one that matters most
for your dental care and it's this that
if you have good habits you are good
okay
that means brushing for two minutes
twice a day and flossing regularly no
matter what brand you use quip makes
that simple starting with an electric
toothbrush refillable floss and anti
cavity toothpaste quip
electric toothbrush has sensitive sonic
vibrations with a built-in timer and
30-second pulses to guide a full and
even clean now here's the thing - you
don't want to be going out and getting
this stuff now okay so use quip they'll
send it to you the dispenser comes with
pre-marked string to help you use just
enough and quip delivers fresh brush
head floss and toothpaste refills to
your door every three months with free
shipping so your routine is always right
you don't have to go anywhere that's
awesome dude if you go to get quip comm
/ Congrats
right now you'll get your first refill
free and that your first refill free at
get quip comm / Congrats spelled GE t qu
IP comm / Congrats quip the good habits
company nice right we're doing it we're
doing it nice okay so we're doing it
nice means absolutely nothing uh people
are nuts about this [ __ ] thing though
going on how crazy it is I went to go
get a coffee and by that I mean I was
out taking a drive not losing my mind
you know just keeping it [ __ ] nice so
my brain doesn't go and all of a sudden
I start believing in pizza gate but what
I did was I stopped in a [ __ ] coffee
bean until 8:00 now you know you know if
you listen to this podcast from jump
that your boy ran that block back in
Sherman Oaks and I don't like to talk
about it that much anymore because it
[ __ ] brings it to your to my eyes and
I don't have enough toilet paper to wipe
the [ __ ] I mean I do now because I
thanks for the manager at [ __ ]
Walgreens but toilet paper is scarce so
what I'm saying is yeah you use you know
I used to keep the block hot you know if
you know me two things
I'm down for [ __ ] and sucking in the
log cabin
I love stand-up comedy I love my family
and also the thing I'm talking about
which I [ __ ] forgot what was it the
[ __ ] oh I ran it kept the block hot
I'm [ __ ] cold water coffee bean I
kept that block so [ __ ] hot I swear
to god people thought it was going to
erupt now that's just the [ __ ] that
was the word on my block now I didn't
make that that was what people were
saying people said to me what's up with
this concrete why is it
says Olin right don't want to get into
it too much but I kept that blog [ __ ]
hot dude I would go BG to go I would get
the Cobb salad I would [ __ ] hop on
over like I was in the children's book
and just walk into that coffee bean I'd
say hello to an old racist guy and I'd
be like when I said Myra Cano please and
that guy was a racist as [ __ ] he's
probably dead now but he one time he was
on a flip phone saying yes I know he's
busy but I'm trying to get in touch with
the mayor yes I understand I know but I
want to talk to the mayor about what
he's doing with all these illegal
immigrants okay cool that's what he said
so that's how you know this huh coffee
bean was hot as [ __ ] but this guy one
time a guy came in with a I don't even
know what to call that I'm I don't want
to be racist but it was a black guy and
he was wearing one of those things that
just you don't see in America you see
him like Africa maybe he was African I
have heard no idea but one of those
things that was just one piece that but
all wrapped around it was like Trump's
hair you know where life starts
somewhere but you don't know where but
that's what this African guy was wearing
just well one piece no pants no shirt
one piece that was just wrapping around
his [ __ ] his [ __ ] shoulder his feet
you know and he was just floating in
like Orca from he-man and he got the
thing and the racist guy the old guy
said hey when in Roma and I go well
what's this about he says when in Roma
and the guy says excuse me sir yes he
says why don't you dress like us and I
go I knew what was gonna happen I knew
that the guy being talked to is gonna be
so peaceful just cuz what he's wearing
people who wear stuff like that are
super peaceful you know what I'm talking
about the more articles of clothing you
have the less peaceful you are like if
you have one thing [ __ ] wrapped around
a toga or if you're wearing nothing you
know how peaceful you are beautiful leaf
around your [ __ ] but this old guy had on
[ __ ] jeans shoes a button-down a
[ __ ] shirt over it and also a
briefcase he would bring a briefcase
like an old-school one that looked like
a Lego like a briefcase not a duffel a
briefcase put it on the [ __ ] table
open it up like it was the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that Pulp Fiction centered around with
the gold inside of it and he would open
it up and I [ __ ] you not
dude this guy would pull out Nesquik in
his briefcase and whenever he got from
the [ __ ] bar he would put Nesquik in
it stir it around put it back in his
brief face case close it up all right
now here's the thing you know that guy's
racist just from the briefcase but this
guy came in and the guy goes like this
when in Roma and he says excuse me sir
what he says why don't you dress like us
you're far from home this is America and
the and the guy said you know what III
should why don't I yeah man maybe I
should yeah you know what to say but
then he was like I pray for you sir and
he left and I was like god damn dude to
be that outwardly racist before Trump is
crazy
all right anyway I kept that black heart
and the coffee bean his begin become my
mainstay and I've been through a lot of
[ __ ] with coffee bean man sometimes I
drink the coffee when I first heard the
call I was like the coffee sucks and
then I started liking it and then I
started drinking [ __ ] different
coffee that people were like but this is
the hot [ __ ] I don't like the [ __ ]
boutique coffee shops they often often
overdo their [ __ ] and I'm not about that
life do it and I'm also not about the
[ __ ] sweet brown like the brownie put
the Duncan Hines [ __ ] in the oven I'll
scarf it down you don't I don't want
[ __ ] extra [ __ ] on the thing I don't
go to a gourmet place you know there's
always like some new place popping up in
LA that's just like hey you got to check
out it's just a [ __ ] artisanal ice
cream place oh yeah
put the haagen-dazs in my [ __ ] mouth
I'm not taking it
yeah but to give you a pretzel to
[ __ ] scoop it out with and you eat it
with the pretzel oh yeah go [ __ ]
yourself ice creams been around for
[ __ ] centuries ice creams literally
been around for billions of years
literally billions of years billions of
ice creams all around the world from
different times and anyway I [ __ ]
take my ice cream haagen-dazs one time I
was in a [ __ ] my mom suburban as a
high school kid and I'm Emma and and one
of her cousins sons was over and he was
so funny he's from New Jersey and my
brother said my brothers talk about how
a girl liked him and he said yeah well I
can't help but she
my haagen-dazs and my [ __ ] friend
from New Jersey says oh you got
haagen-dazs back there and I pulled over
and laughed dude I got haagen-dazs back
there oh [ __ ] man I love [ __ ] like that
so anyway I keep the block [ __ ] hot
coffee Ben and I we've been together
dude we're an odd couple you understand
so so I go to this coffee bean during
this pandemic I got my n95 mask on I got
my [ __ ] hands and my shits you know
I'm touching doors if I have to if I'm
not I don't if I'm with someone which I
never am I haven't touched you know none
of my friends I go like this you open it
you get it you get it you get kovat and
they [ __ ] go all right I guess I'm
you know maybe gonna get Cove it and I
walk in the thing and I got my hand 95
masks and my buddy mark is there the guy
who opens for me sometimes and he's
Irish and he goes like this a lot Oh
seriously or begins every sentence with
here here what time is the show why'd
you say here at the beginning of that
[ __ ] why are you adding words so
I'm there and a guy walks in with a mask
a [ __ ] mask you know one of those
[ __ ] ones that nurses wear and also a
[ __ ] headband with a glass shield
over it homemade
now the guys in his 70s okay and I
respect it I'm like alright this guy is
taking this [ __ ] kovat [ __ ] seriously
he's also a little bit older more at
risk you know maybe Brian Collins age
and I'm like that's great so he says to
oh by the way mark is a color that
doesn't exist I should have started this
with this my friend mark is a color that
doesn't exist yet do you understand he's
a mix of translucent and bad
okay it was like the movie remember the
movie powder how the guy was so white
like mark would have auditioned for this
and they would have been like well we
need it to be more believable so we're
gonna use the guy and just put actual
makeup on him we want people to watch it
because mark looks like a potato that we
left out too long
understand so and his [ __ ] head hair
our pubes so he uh yeah so so like when
he gets a haircut they say what do you
want he says here pubes and so so he is
always translucent and beige okay and
he's because of this there's definitely
something going on with his [ __ ]
immune system and Mark's been sniffling
since I've met him since I've met him he
be like oh here and you're just like
he's dead and I had just an Irish thing
like I don't know so he's doing his mark
[ __ ] and the [ __ ] 70 something year
old says hey man your sniffling from
across the coffee bean and I go I miss
this place man this guy's the new
[ __ ] racist guy this block is hot now
coffee bean is where it's at there's
always one crazy person in a coffee shop
and when that person leaves ding ding
ding another guy comes in and is like
you guys heard a pizza gate so this guy
says hey you're sniffling and Mark says
something that I understand but the guy
doesn't understand because when Mark
talks for the first time to somebody
he's inaudible because he's so Irish my
brother
I remember once my brother when he met
mark mark said something I hear I and my
brother said what just like that and I
fell out ok now this guy said mark says
here I yeah it's just say it's nothing
and the guy says what you shouldn't be
out and mark goes I he looks at me and
he's like no it's just sniffling it's
nothing I don't have it and I'm like oh
wait
ahoo [ __ ] yeah Kove it and so um so the
guy says yeah you're sniffling you
shouldn't be out and I'm laughing dude
because your boys a [ __ ] there do
well I'm loving it I'm like this I'm
like a goalie before they [ __ ] drop
that soccer ball in right and and he and
he says yeah you you you you if you're
compromised you shouldn't be out in
public you should be wearing a mask at
least and I'm like hey man he he doesn't
have it he's [ __ ] always snappin on
the guy for every doesn't have it he's
he's always sniffling it [ __ ] his
annoying as [ __ ] it's one of his things
it's a tic I said and the guy says yeah
well I'm some I'm 72 so you know if I
get it it's bad news and I was like
buddy it's all good don't worry about it
and that was when I was like man I could
really see this [ __ ] going that getting
out of control
I could could really see this [ __ ]
getting to that was like a step away
from fighting mark oh he's one of the
guys that always gets in one of those
situations man I have another buddy like
that it's a different way like he always
finds himself into these Curb Your
Enthusiasm moments mm-hmm one time he
was in a 7-eleven and this guy was in
front of him and he was waiting in line
and he had a [ __ ] pocket it sure with
a pocket on it okay and he looked at the
counter and saw this gum pack and he was
like all that gum pack looks exactly
like it with the size of my pocket and
so he picked it up to see if it was the
size of the pocket he was like it fit
perfectly and the guy in front of him
that was checking out said okay thanks
to the guy who was do who he was ringing
him up and he said by the way this guy's
trying to steal steal some gum and then
the guy goes no I I wasn't trying to
steal gum I I actually was just uh I was
seeing if this is what he says which
makes it worse I was seeing if the gum
fit in my pocket because it looked like
it fit in the pocket you know what and
they paid and then he let the guy keep
the change cuz he felt guilty Larry
David and that's a real [ __ ] story for
that ass and they should do a biopic
where Tom Hardy plays that guy or [ __ ]
Colin Firth
I was trying to pick I was trying to see
if let I died
King speech - 7 - 7 eleven chronicles
Wow
King speech to the 7-eleven chronicles
the worst [ __ ] title for any [ __ ]
movie of all time but that's the title
of this podcast of course King speech -
the [ __ ] 7-eleven chronicles dude I
gotta tell you man I've got some cool -
good news is coming up
and I'm not gonna tell you what it is
but I've got one good news and then I've
got another good news and I'm not even
gonna tell you what it is and I can't
[ __ ] wait dude I can't wait to drop
the [ __ ] and it has nothing to do with
the special and it has nothing to do you
know with this special that's it that
was the sentence but um yeah that's
about it
should we do second dad's second dad's
tomb in two minutes okay cool he's
saying in two minutes
Oh Jeremy oh dude here's what I'll do
Jeremy Renner's album came out the new
Jeremy Renner Renner album have you guys
[ __ ] heard it yet I haven't but I'm
going to Jeremy Renner we love Jeremy
Renner at the [ __ ] log cabin uh I
[ __ ] love guys like that dude we were
[ __ ] poking out him lightly on the
podcast and the dude reached out and
said he liked it
I love guys like that dude because I was
telling this [ __ ] story on your mom's
house recently that Tom Segura podcast
it's coming out in next week but on the
day of my special but my episode but you
know this guy was talking to me I tell
the story on your mom's house and it was
this guy I was at the Comedy Store and
there were these four other guys there
that I hadn't seen in a long time and
another guy did join the conversation
just a lurker you know that the Comedy
Store they have him a lot right so he
started taking the come over the
conversation nobody knew the guy but my
friends thought maybe I knew the guy and
then the guy said something and I went
oh who are you like that and my and that
was the moment where that my friends
realized that I didn't know the guy and
they just started laughing crying
laughing right but make no mistake
because I did that it doesn't mean that
I don't like that guy it was a matter of
fact I love people who do that [ __ ]
because all people make up this world
and this world is great
as this world is life and life rips okay
I've actually got three good news is
that I can I can drop on you dude your
boys [ __ ] um coming up I want the
world to know to let it show taking
liberties and um coming up oh I want the
world to know taking [ __ ] liberties
because that's what I do cuz I'm a good
singer dude you're here [ __ ] guy like
in line or some [ __ ] and he's just like
doing a song and he makes his own little
twist on it at the line of [ __ ]
7-eleven and you're like dude taking
[ __ ] liberties dude anyway dude the
new Jeremy Renner album is coming out or
it came out and I can't wait to [ __ ]
listen to it dude there's a [ __ ]
picture of him laying on his piano like
this and I'm like I'm all-in dude I'm
[ __ ] all-in he's opening up his soul
laying down on the piano I'm all-in if
somebody opens up their soul in their
music to it that's why I like that
[ __ ] nope danno shoe bad Adam for the
very first time that I saw your brown
eyes in your lips at hello and I said hi
I knew that we were more than just of
but I was caught up in physical
attraction and then this part but to my
satisfaction sit taking liberties
because I feel it's my soul dude take a
Liberty I will be sure that the lady
because I go sure that because I can't
cuz I didn't go sure
I went sure that and that's [ __ ]
taking liberties dude guys the last
degree of Kevin Bacon is a new Spotify
original podcast can bacon is cool do
you know why cuz he's been around for a
long time in Hollywood do you know how
[ __ ] hard that is is very hard you
boys only been around for like six years
Kevin's fake Kevin's bacon Kevin Bacon's
been around for about six decades and
somehow he's miraculously only 45 but
this podcast is great it's a fictional
comedy podcast from Spotify and Funny or
Die called the last degree of Kevin
Bacon the premise of the show is that 36
years ago a guy named Randy B's lo
narrowly lost the starring role in
Footloose to Kevin Bacon and has been
obsessed with him ever since so Randy
has finally hit his breaking point and
vows to go to LA kill his enemy and
replace him in the universe but things
don't go quite as planned
though when he gets there because what
exactly do you do when your mortal enemy
just wants you to be his best friend the
last degree of Kevin Bacon stars Kevin
Bacon
Carrie Sedgwick isn't it - and she's
awesome Matt Walsh from veep plays Randy
be slow or mourn Morris stars in the
show as well and it features Rob Reiner
Emily Deschanel Rhea Perlman Natalie
Morales Michaela Watkins and Terry Gross
it's gonna be hilarious the last the
last degree of Kevin Bacon is to Spotify
original podcast and you can listen to
it for free only on spot of Spotify so
go check that out
Roman most of you guys have tried
different ways to last longer but saying
the Pledge of Allegiance in your head or
counting backwards from ten doesn't
always work I used to think about tennis
because I [ __ ] hate tennis and it's
boring and the number one thing I'm not
doing when I'm playing tennis is busting
a ton
the folks at Roman a men's health
company are changing the game with Roman
swipes the secret to log or lasting sex
swipes are a clinically proven way to
last longer in bed they're effective
easy to use and fast-acting but don't
require a prescription Roman can ship
swipes to you in discreet unmarked
packaging and each swipes packet is
small enough to hide in your wallet for
whatever you need it
swipes are great they will not transfer
to your partner so you can just last
longer without worryin
they're super easy to use just take
swipes out of the package way but don't
let it dry and then you're good to go
that's it get $10 off your first order
of swipes and free today shipping at get
Roman comm such babies let's get Roman
comm / babies for $10 off and free
two-day shipping get Roman comm / babies
but I was caught up in physical
attraction but - that's good I don't
give a [ __ ] what you say I sing good man
I should practice harder I went to
[ __ ] Whole Foods and [ __ ] Whole
Foods is well it's good I went to Whole
Foods I want to [ __ ] another one and
my girl wanted me to get [ __ ] heavy
cream heavy whipped whipped cream heavy
whipping heavy whipping by the way and
here's the thing don't if you say how is
there something called whipped cream and
then also something called whipping
cream
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] kidding me
so she's like get whip get whipping
cream heavy whipping cream and I'm like
alright and I go I look there's none so
I [ __ ] didn't get it in the second
time remember get that heavy whipping
cream so I go I look and I ask the lady
and I say hey I don't see whipping cream
and she's like um I think it's over
there but it's made out of rice there
and I look and it says whipped cream and
I was like you know what if whipping
cream is this hard to get [ __ ] it I'm
getting whipped cream that's what I'm
getting and that's what we have now and
it's not my fault dude it's [ __ ] the
people who labelled it's fault nothing's
ever been my fault and I was caught up
in physical attraction
and I was caught up chick ah in physical
attraction that's cool to do it like
that who sings that shy
did they sing anything else how about
[ __ ] more celebrities and people in
Hollywood that [ __ ] are just so
tone-deaf in the pandemic David Geffen's
Instagram post sunset last night
isolated in the Grenadines is that he
say it avoiding the virus I'm hoping
everyone is staying safe and he's on his
boat the size of a cruise ship and it's
a picture of his boat which means he
also has a helicopter because that's
where the photos from no it's all good
but and it's fine but Oh baby hat um I
just love it to be I want to be a god
bless [ __ ] David Geffen I want to be
that for real just so deep in it how
much is a carton of milk fifty five
dollars just saying [ __ ] not knowing
people don't make beds anymore right
just saying [ __ ] just so not aware what
are you talking about clean it up
don't they have people with the
government that do that and you're like
this is your house oh my bad
just on your rocket pack leaving bye-bye
[Music]
how about that one [ __ ] clip of the
guy who are the news we've done that in
this podcast right the news guy the news
guy that says well that is on the jet
pack and then [ __ ] it tries to get out
off the dock and goes right into the
ocean have we made fun of that let me
look at that look that up news have we
water jet
hack my dog dad died for sure dog just
went here this the Boat Show coming up
so funny dude I'm live here at the San
Diego Yacht & Boat Show good morning
everybody first of all the [ __ ]
newscaster has the worst green
button-down shirt on and he has his arm
around the guy who has a jetpack on hey
man if you have a jetpack on don't be so
chummy you'll burn yourself so the guy
just just by the way it's Fox 69 News
which is like Gila one up-or-down
hanging out with my friend John hate
each other yeah [ __ ] does [ __ ] his
boyfriend they're all gay for sure
they're all gay here at the San Diego
Yacht & Boat Show good morning everybody
I'm hanging out with my friend John
knows damn well that he [ __ ] his
boyfriend and is not gonna say anything
and the guy knows he knows that he
[ __ ] his boyfriend that's Heather
acting dude and they're so close he's
got his [ __ ] arm all chummy and the
guy knows that he [ __ ] his girl his
boyfriend and he's like I can't wait to
rub it in his face and just [ __ ]
jetpack out of here dude what's mine is
mine and then gets [ __ ] Fox 5 Morning
News starts look over there and it
starts right now
and it starts right now huh dude the
[ __ ] little whimper of and it starts
right now
wow dude San Diego Yacht and boat joke
of course it's San Diego look at this
[ __ ] newscaster morning everybody I'm
hanging out with my friend John Fox 5
Morning News starts look over there and
it starts right now just the greatest
thing to ever happen shadow that up oh
I'll sing for you guys this could be a
singing podcast for the very first time
when I saw your brown eyes sake I'm
annoyed at myself um um okay it's been
49 [ __ ] minutes Jesus Christ what I
do it for the next 11 minutes uh oh I
have to you know I have to do is oh I
gotta tell you remember I told you that
[ __ ] story last week about my dad and
about the nude matte the nude clippings
that I had he heard it and he told me
you forgot some parts and so I should
fill in the parts so I here is the
updated version from my dad my dad
already kind of had an inkling about it
because my buddy Matt Ravenna called me
a few days before that and said hey mr.
Dooly is Chris there and I picked it up
and when I picked it up before my dad
hung up the phone
Matt Ravenna said you want to go see the
pictures and my dad hung up the phone I
was like I wonder what thought about
right so the the kid came over and told
on me and my dad said so and he said yes
so I just don't know I wanted to tell
you and my dad said yeah so now I know
now what and the kid said well I don't
know and that was good because my dad is
a [ __ ] boss player now afterwards my
dad because he went to see the picture
make sure there was no animal [ __ ] or
anything
well look if you really want to see see
a beautiful naked woman look at this and
he had a foot his friend was a
photographer named Marco glove Ianno
I say Italian his name was Marta Coco
yeah I know okay yeah straight upset
Italian so he um he was like he oh he
would photograph naked women like it in
a beautiful way black and white with
[ __ ] it all look like you know film
noir [ __ ] and he said look at that look
at this and my dad starts opening the
page is showing me these beautiful women
nude models and not the [ __ ] girl who
I was looking at with [ __ ] fried
butterflies and and [ __ ] big-ass
melons my buddy in high school used to
say Jimbo and I'd be like what's that
and he'd say jugs I'm a mop about oh
what a [ __ ] goofball so um anyway so
he shows me these this book or this
photography book that Markab laviano did
and all these women beautiful woman and
I look and I'm like the wee-bey me and
I'm like oh this is a woman right and my
my dad said I looked at him and I said I
said does mom know you have this and he
was like yeah yeah no I thought he was
[ __ ] like confiding in me that oh
[ __ ]
alright I'll keep it cool I won't tell
mom you had this photo book of Marco
glove y'know anyway dude I would go in
and I would look at that every after
after that I remember I would go in and
look at it when my dad wasn't in his
offices sometimes I show my friends
that's crazy man it's crazy how [ __ ]
the [ __ ] you remember you know and it's
crazy to think when you have a kid that
like my kid is gonna have that those
moments and he's gonna have moments of
like that just that did you remember
it's something we're gonna be important
to some of them aren't you know they
can't remember one time I was a
preschool pre-k or whatever the [ __ ] and
this girl I was eating wafers those
those DUHS wafers
I always said would have these vanilla
wafers I love them do it
my mom wouldn't get him enough you know
and I was eating them and then she was
eating her whatever dessert was it was
dessert time you know and she was eating
the the wafers and taking the smallest
bites the smallest bites now we were
both small but she was taking the
smallest bites and I was like looking at
her while I was eating the food brought
a shovel [ __ ] in my mouth I don't even
use my hands sometime I just go like
this and I'm like and then move forward
on the [ __ ] table as I Chomp it's
like that it's like a conveyor belt at
the end of a horror movie where
somebody's like no no they get smashed
in the head anyway that's my [ __ ]
that's how the food's getting into my
mouth I don't [ __ ] there's always
gonna be food - people say why do you
eat so fast because I always want the
food in my mouth the second I swallow it
I put more food in my mouth because the
sensation is the best in the [ __ ]
mouth I don't want to swallow wait a
little bit and just suck on air I want
to [ __ ] eat the [ __ ] and it tastes
good and yum yum it tastes [ __ ] good
and yum yum it tastes [ __ ] good and
then I swallow it and then I put another
[ __ ] piece in my mouth because
because it's [ __ ] sensation because
his [ __ ] sensation and this girl was
eating the smallest bites and in my
little head I was like I you know how
old are you when you go to pre Cairo for
I don't know younger I 3 I I was like am
I gonna say something to this girl am I
gonna [ __ ] it cuz what what is she
doing she needs to know that she has to
have more of the food in her mouth to
hit all the taste bud
and then when she swallows she needs to
put another [ __ ] mouthful in there so
it's at maximum [ __ ] fun capacity in
her mouth understand this is the [ __ ] I
was breaking down as a three-year-old
and she's chomping little [ __ ] nibble
ass mouse bites and I look at her and
now I can't help myself cuz I'm like I
gotta say some because I got to know
what the [ __ ] she's doing like I know
why she's doing it because am I gonna
teach her how to [ __ ] eat like what's
the deal she was younger than me do I
remember and I say hey and she says yeah
I thought she was so cute even as a
three-year-old she was maybe two and I
was like ah she's so cute
but she was I was like why taking such
small bite and she [ __ ] looked at me
and she says because then it lasts
longer and I couldn't really argue with
that you know if she [ __ ] taught me
and I thought I was gonna [ __ ] teach
her so the moral the story is a
two-year-old can teach a three-year-old
something but I still take [ __ ]
monster bites dude I've never taken a
small bite but my point is I think of
that all the [ __ ] time I think of it
all the time
I don't know who that girl is I don't
remember her name I think she was
Mexican or something maybe Puerto Rican
because we were on the east coast but
dude I think about it all the time I
think about it often when I'm eating
while I'm taking my big ass bites you
never know what's gonna shape you it
could be the nudie magazines it could be
the small bites to the [ __ ] girl
sitting next to you but that's what
makes you who you are and that's [ __ ]
beautiful dude that's [ __ ] beautiful
yeah I remember what you said that too I
thought oh I'd rather it go quick and
just get the [ __ ] maximum phone
capacity in my mouth because it's more
sensational sensational sensational
sensational being a kid was the [ __ ] man
Enoch
the [ __ ] I guess you get to relive those
moments you know when you have a kid I
hope so
that would be very cool very nice and
very special but what's it gonna say
it's gonna tell you another story about
the [ __ ] this [ __ ] that I don't
remember I'll remember for next time but
it's funny to think of the fact that
like you know people who are like people
who are like David Geffen on a boat that
they had those moments too and now
they're taking pictures from their
helicopter of their boat telling
everybody just stay safe
God wait I know what I actually want to
talk about for the before I even [ __ ]
sign off here this new meme holy [ __ ]
[ __ ]
this new meme of the guise of someone
doing something deadly and then before
they get hurt or die the [ __ ] guys
dance around with a casket have you seen
this bro the remember the meme ladies
and gentlemen we got him the when they
got bin Laden and Drake would be like
yeah I text [ __ ] that
fourteen-year-old girl all the time and
there'd be like ladies and gentlemen we
got him draw that meme to me was so
funny but I think this one beats it
there's a whole threat of it that this
guy named Dan Nolan
dude the guy jumped drives off a bridge
and then these [ __ ] dudes are just
first of all who they are they African
or what wherever this is that they're
doing this they take funerals seriously
imagine the [ __ ] body in the casket
they're just like doing this to the body
and the cash is just like bro you know
god these memes do it they're so funny
the one of my favorite ones is the Girt
that got that it's zooming in on a
girl's butt and then it [ __ ] pans
over to the girl guys girlfriend looking
at him [ __ ] dude you got to looked at
meme up it's from Dan Nolan i retweeted
it a few days ago but holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
man it was killing me crying dude well
how about this [ __ ] so hyoe parking lot
is a woman who just attended a church
service with dozens of other people
including children can I ask you about
your decision to go to church to be
inside that building I wouldn't be
anywhere else aren't you concerned you
could in fact other people if you get
sick inside that's as a reporter I go
when she says I'm covered in Jesus's
blood I go like this thank you for your
time ma'am thank you for your time
you're a crazy person ma'am I'm going to
go interview somebody who has something
worthwhile to say bro I love how the
reporters are so far away from the
people that the reporting nowadays -
they're always like it's like they're
doing [ __ ] sound on NCIS hello would
you like to talk about the new bakery
opening I'm covered in Jesus hey hey no
you're not
like breaking it down in any way you
want to any way shape or form you're not
covered in Jesus blood and if you were
you've got to take a shower that's
unsanitary
butter this church who you might have
all of these people go to this church
but you're gonna be in places where
other
Krister everyday I'm in Walmart Home
Depot I'm gonna get them sick for what
happens it could get me sick but they're
not because I'm covered in his blood
thank you very much
Wow dude dropping a slam dude thank you
very much I'm covered in Jesus's blood
they're not getting me sick because I'm
covered in Jesus's blood thank you very
much I'm not sure I'm not gonna be I'm
not gonna be [ __ ] I'm covered in
Jesus's blood thank you very much uh I
mean this lady you know she's gonna
happen buddy has kids hopefully her kids
[ __ ] think she's a [ __ ]
too-hoo real and then I put a [ __ ]
thing up but you know how every
celebrities doing like this is how long
you wash your hands for you got to sing
this song and I did the Josh Groban song
you raised me up and I [ __ ] left the
sink running while I was washing my
hands and so many [ __ ] cooks in the
comment we're like Oh real cool you left
the water running there's a drought and
this and that wasting water s mhm dude
hey man you know how easy it is to be a
[ __ ] Holy Roller on the Internet
I'm sure you waste some [ __ ] water
it's so these people who just up a
little you're a [ __ ] keyboard warrior
bro you don't know you don't know real
life all right I wasted some [ __ ]
water who just doesn't even if you
really think you're like I wasted some
what I had whatever I'm not gonna
comment alright dude I'm done you guys
we killed it and by we I mean me you
could text me eight one eight two three
nine 7087
you text me right then that's eight one
eight two three nine 7087 and more
importantly my podcast I run my podcast
my special comes out on April 14th
called no pain on Netflix no pain on
Netflix you watch that as soon as it
drops that's awesome
you guys are great thanks so much
appreciate you guys and [ __ ] I got four
things I got to tell you guys that I
haven't told you yet it is amazing Wow
all right you guys are great thank you
so much
and talk to you talk to you later
[Music]